[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Phil?
>> Pretty good.
>> Welcome home.
>> It's great to be home.
But I couldn't help but
be really pleased to see the dean
wearing a business suit and
Nike shoes showing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I think we can all be, and
we can all be glad that basically I was
not the founder of Jockey underwear.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We'll try and
make that a permanent change
in Dean Levin's wardrobe.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now Phil,
we know you don't do too
many public speaking events.
And a question a lot of people have
asked is what does it take to get
Phil Knight up on stage?
So I thought maybe we should share
the story of what got you here today.
Now, you probably remember that we
first crossed paths a couple of months
ago just over there at McDonald Hall.
You were entering the building when
I very politely interrupted you,
introduced myself.
We exchanged a couple of pleasantries, and
then you went on inside about your day.
Now what you're probably less aware of,
Phil,
is that I decide to camp outside
McDonald Hall for the next 40 minutes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Watching every possible human exit to
the building so that I could find you, and
casually bump into you a second time,
to pitch you this interview.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's creepy, I know.
>> Yeah, but that's how it happened.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'll be honest,
I was pretty nervous when you did
come out out that second time.
It was fight or flight,
I very nearly walked the other way.
But there was this voice in my head.
It just kept saying, Will, just do it.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> But really, Phil, we are so
thrilled and
excited to have you back on campus.
And I think I speak for every student
here when I say how grateful we are for
this incredible business school.
>> Well, thank you, but
having stalked me for at least 40 minutes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I feel that there should be some
payback.
>> Don't do it.
>> And
I know that most of you know
that Will's mother, Mags,
has come all the way from
Ireland to be here today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And having come such a long way,
I think you should reveal something
about yourself that she doesn't know.
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> Phil,
I don't know what you're
trying to suggest.
I was a perfect child.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well,
did you make your bed this morning?
>> I didn't even sleep in my own bed this
morning-
>> Well-
>> because I gave it to my mom!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I gave it to my mom.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That wasn't what it sounded like.
>> All right, now Phil.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Phil,
we don't want to make you feel old,
this is payback by the way.
>> Yeah, this could go back and
forth a long time, that's right.
>> But it's been almost 60 years-
>> Yep.
>> Since you were here in our shoes,
an incoming MBA, class of 1962.
What kind of person was
Phil Knight back at the GSB?
How would you have described yourself?
>> Yeah, I will.
But I want to tell you first
about coming back to campus,
after being gone for a while.
That you go out 20 years or so, and
you haven't been back for a while, and
you come back, and it's more about just
sharing a moment with family and friends.
It's for a moment,
you step back in history and
remember when you had all
the world laying out before you.
And you decided the things you
were going to find important,
and it was really the start of you
becoming what you ultimately became.
When I come back, for just a moment,
I always hear the voice of Frank
Shallenberger, Bob Davis, Jim Porterfield.
And I know that sounds sort of
corny to an educated group.
But I promise you that over
half the people in this room,
when they come back here 20 years from
now, will have those same feelings.
For me it was, well, yeah,
that I was the guy that thought
an extrovert was the person that
stared at other people's shoes.
That it was a time for
me to kind of grow and
chase what I was really going to become.
And so it's really a big,
transitional period for me in my life.
And as I say to this day, when I come
back, I still get inspired and lifted up.
>> Do have any favorite memories
from your days back at Stanford?
>> That it was just a turning point in
general for me, that if I was honest,
I'd say that my undergraduate
career was really focused on track.
And it got to be,
when I got to be a graduate student,
that I was really focused on
what it was I wanted to be.
And this was just the right school at the
right time, with the right inspirational
professors, and it really doesn't
get any better than that.
>> So you do graduate the GSB in 1962.
>> Yep.
>> This is a time when Silicon Valley
isn't even a phrase yet.
>> Right.
>> And
you had what you call this crazy idea.
What was the crazy idea and
where did it come about?
>> Well, I took the entrepreneurship
class from Frank Shallenberger.
And basically the project,
he had a term project
where you basically either attach
yourself to a company in the area, or for
the purpose of the paper, made up
a company and how it would succeed.
And even in those days, a lot of my
classmates were writing about electronics.
Which was certainly beyond me,
since when I turn on an electric switch,
the light bulb comes on,
it's magic for me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
my old track coach was always working with
shoes, and felt that a light weight in
shoes was something that was neglected by
the major manufacturers, Adidas and Puma.
And indeed, my senior year, Otis Davis won
the Pacific Coast Conference championship
in a pair of homemade Bowerman shoes,
which were an ounce lighter
than the other shoes.
So I kind of put those things together,
and
said if you were starting a shoe factory,
would you start it in Germany?
And I said it's such
a labor intensive business,
it makes more sense to start it in Japan.
Japan being a country that took German
cameras, and dominated the camera markets,
I said, could they do the same
thing in sport shoes?
And that was really the thesis of the
paper which ultimately I got caught up in,
and here we are.
>> Now, you got an A on that paper, right?
>> I did.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That mattered.
If he had ridiculed the paper,
I don't know where we'd be today.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
Phil, this was a time when
entrepreneurship post-GSB was not just
a less traveled path,
it was probably a less celebrated path.
What gave you the confidence
to push ahead?
>> Well, if I didn't,
I was going to have to be an accountant.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, I know that's a scary thought.
>> No, it was-
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, but it was when I wrote the paper,
it just stayed in my head.
And at the time, I think the ratio was
that 26 out of 27 new companies failed.
So I knew the odds weren't high.
But I really began to feel if I could do
this, that it would really be meaningful
to me, and something that I would really
have a lot of passion for and about.
And so that's where it started and
the way it will end.
>> Now, two years in
Many of your classmates have gone
down more traditional career paths.
You're back in Oregon, you're living
in your old room in the family house,
and you're selling shoes out
of the trunk of your car.
Did you ever have doubts in those moments,
and what was it that kept you going?
>> [LAUGH] Well obviously,
there were a lot of doubts, but
I enjoyed what I was doing, and
I really thought that I was
bringing a product to the world
that was better than the other product and
so I believed.
And if you read the book,
it wasn't too long before I had a bunch
of other people that believed as well.
And we just through all the ups and
downs and there were plenty of downs
that we never stopped believing.
And a lot of people say,
why did you stay with it?
There were a lot of negative moments and
a lot of downturns.
And I look back on those days
the most fun I ever had in business.
Every Monday you went to work and
you knew it mattered what you did,
including whether you're
going to meet payroll on Friday.
But it was an exciting time
that Frank Shellenberger
had done a wonderful job of preparing
us for being an entrepreneur.
Bob Davis, a marketing professor said,
if you're going to be an entrepreneur,
he said, everyday's a crisis and
every Friday is a Jesus crisis.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And that was kind of the way it was.
[LAUGH]
>> Now you also talk in your book,
Shoe Dog, about those early trips to Asia.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you're 24 years old, traveling alone
to Japan, it's a culture you don't know,
a language you don't speak, to try and
broker that first shoe import deal.
So this was a time before Stanford's
global study trips or GMIXs.
Where did that ability to embrace hustle
and uncertainty come from in you?
>> Well,
by the time I got there I believed, and so
I believed that that was a good idea,
I believed that
if we could get a cooperative
Japanese factory,
that we could make the idea work,
and so I overcame, I'm an introvert.
Well, you're basically you have to
believe, you have to overcome the shyness
to take certain chances and
I was willing to do that, and
there were a lot of ups and
downs, but ultimately it worked.
And I think at the end of
the day you gotta believe.
And that's what I did have
maybe above everything else.
>> Now as you said, the team grew and
you weren't alone in this endeavor.
And I think there's no story of
Nike without, of course, mentioning
Bill Bowerman, your former track coach at
Oregon, later US Olympic's track coach.
And of course,
your co-founder of what became Nike.
You've described yourself as
a person whose always needed heroes.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Why was Bill a hero to you and
what is it you learned from him?
>> Well he was a very unique person
that he was probably the best track and
field coach in the world, for one thing.
But he also had a certain command
presence and a certain belief and
certain leadership
things that leaders did.
He said, I'm not a track coach, he says,
I'm a professor of competitive response.
And he had a way of having sayings
that got your attention and
really focused you on attitude.
The strategy for
running the mile was start out and
run the first two laps
at a very fast pace.
Run the third lap as fast as you can,
run the fourth lap, triple your speed.
And he said, the Oregon Trail,
he says, the cowards never started and
the weak died along the way,
that leaves you and me.
And that's once again,
him getting in kind of your attitude and
his best one for me was always,
do right and fear no man.
And so he had a big influence on my life,
certainly the biggest influence
other than my parents.
And if you go back through the sayings and
who he was,
he was always working on attitude.
This is a man that had seen combat
in World War II, fired a gun and
been fired at, and he had seen
competition at its most extreme level.
And he thought his job
as a professor of competitive response
was to get kids ready, young men and
young women, ultimately to be ready for
the toughest competition they can face.
So he brought, to me, a certain attitude,
which you can be an introvert and
have attitude, so that was sort of me.
And he had a huge influence on that,
and he was a hero of mine,
in those days, and unto this day.
>> When you first met him, you described
it as love and fear at first sight.
>> Right, and then there's little
hate that came after that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He really kind of believed in hazing,
that you had to prove that
you wanted to be there.
And so he would make you go through hoops,
which I did, somewhat reluctantly.
>> Now beyond Bill of course,
you talk with a lot of affection
about that core early Nike team.
And I think you had a name for
each other, right?
>> Well yeah, we did.
>> I see you're playing that game.
>> [LAUGH] Now, the first four or
five people of the company,
we wound up calling each other butt
faces which, we don't do that anymore.
We're
>> [LAUGH]
>> More professional group now.
>> [LAUGH] You know from the top team,
reached a similar name for
each other actually.
>> It's good, that's healthy.
>> But what was it about that early
team and that culture that made it so
successful?
>> Well I think first of all, they
were a bizarre group to say the least.
Each of them, in his own way,
but they were,
and I hope this showed in the book,
that they were able,
very able people that really kind of
didn't get along with society in general.
So it was kind of a perfect fit.
And they complimented each other
in terms of their abilities.
And then lastly, all of them believed.
When we would hit a downturn, nobody
thought, this is the end, versus, say,
okay, we've got to get together and
find our way out of this one.
And so it was fun being in
a foxhole with those guys.
And basically, it's corny,
but we loved each other, and
we were going to go through
this come hell or high water.
And It was a very exciting intense time
and it, it's actually, I love those times.
>> You fought a lot of crisis together.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> In recent years Phil,
we've seen many high profile disruptive
companies being pressured to rein in.
What we're seeing is aggressive,
macho, win at all costs cultures,
cultures that have brought these companies
so much early success in their life.
Just last year,
Nike faced some similar accusations and
the management team made some
pretty decisive changes.
When you grow from a start up to a 74,000
person team, how do you preserve
the best of that winning culture in a more
complex, diverse, global workforce?
>> Yeah,
well you touched on a lot of things there,
I do think that Nike's culture is
a big part of its reason for success.
And the culture really was formed in
the early days by the four people,
plus me, and it still exists to this day.
A lot of people say, well, Phil had a
dominant influence on that, and he didn't.
I've often said many times, Nike is
young and irreverent, and I'm neither.
But it did, to use Burman's word,
it came with a certain attitude.
And it was sort of us.
It's who we were.
And the culture has been modified some,
which is a good thing.
But it's still, kind of,
basically there, and
I thinks its a big part of it's strength.
Yeah, so I hope that that culture is
basically in place 20 years from now.
And it's one thing it fits
with sort of our view then and
now about what a brand is.
It doesn't matter how many
people hate your brand,
as long as enough people love it.
And as long as you have that out,
you can't be afraid of offending people.
You can't try and
go down the middle of the road.
You have to take a stand on something,
which is ultimately,
I think why the Kaepernick ad worked.
>> Well let's jump into those athletes.
So, I want to take you back to 1978, Phil.
You stumble across a shy, timid,
retiring Stanford tennis player
by the name of John McEnroe.
>> Timid, I wouldn't say.
[LAUGH]
>> Well,
we got to see a little bit
of John in that video.
But for anyone who doesn't know tennis
John is a young, fantastic tennis
player who's as well known for
breaking rackets as he is breaking serve.
He is everything that the tennis
establishment at the time,
the major majority of the market, was not.
So what made him the right ambassador for
Nike?
>> Well the story, basically, we
had an agreement with Jimmy Connors'
agent for him to wear Nike shoes.
And he did, he wore them at Wimbledon.
And the agent said, as soon as he gets
back from Wimbledon, we'll get it signed.
Well, he won Wimbledon.
And as soon as he got back from Europe for
he had summer matches and
then came the US Open.
He says, as we get done with the US Open,
we'll get this contract signed.
Well, he won the US Open, and then,
we got down to sign the contract.
And he says, I don't remember it this way.
That was Jimmy Connors' agent,
not Jimmy Connors, himself.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
that was the end of our
endorsement with Jimmy Connors.
[LAUGH] And so, the next year,
I think it was,
that I went to Wimbledon looking for
the next great hope.
And there were a bunch of really good
American, young Americans 18 and under.
I was looking at the 18 and unders.
And they had Brian Godfrey
who was a great player and
Eliot Teltscher is a great player and
the head of USA tennis was saying that
those are really great endorsements.
Stay away from that kid McEnroe
he's too much of a hot head.
He's playing over on court 14 and
I went right for court 14.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And basically that week he was playing
the number 16 player in the world,
Phil Dent, and he's 18 years old and
hits his first serve in and the chalk
flies up and the line judge goes out.
McEnroe jumps over the net, puts his
nose this far from the official and
says are you sure of that call?
Are you very sure of that call?
And I turned to the guy I was with and
said this kid's not afraid.
And I kind of became a fan
of his intensity and
his competitiveness and his attitude.
He did lose control sometimes.
But-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, I always remember Frank DeForge's
write-up of him in Sports Illustrated,
when he said of the big picture of Mac,
and it says, why isn't this man smiling?
Said, Beethoven didn't smile much, either.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's fair.
A few years later, actually, several years
later, you decided to name the executive
building at your headquarters
in Oregon after John McEnroe.
What is it you were trying to say
to the team at Nike in doing that?
>> Well we named all the buildings
after our heroes at the time, and
he was one of them, and
that just that was where my office was.
>> Fair enough.
You're glad to see him back, playing well?
>> And that makes me feel even better.
>> Now, let's fast forward to 1984.
You come across another decent basketball
player whose name is Michael Jordan?
Michael Jordan, that's it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now,
Nike were actually criticized at the time
for overpaying for Jordan's signature.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But of course, with hindsight,
he became more than an athlete,
he became a $2.5 billion revenue brand for
Nike.
Beyond MJ's greatness,
what was it that made that brand so
successful, and so dominant?
>> Yeah,
it isn't something you can bottle.
It's been truly one of
the unique experiences really,
in all of marketing,
that obviously he had it all.
And we pretty much knew that coming in.
I mean, he was player of the year,
he was handsome, he could jump, and
that he won the national
championship with the winning shot.
He had all of it, and when we signed him,
we signed him for
more than any rookie had been paid before.
We signed him for $250,000 a year, and
Fortune magazine ran a little
insert in another article.
It says there's no greater indication that
Nike has lost its way than the fact that
they paid Michael Jordan $250,000.
But we combined it with
what we thought was
a really good shoe,
a really distinctive shoe.
It was red and
black it wasn't just white or black.
And of course he wore it
in great performances.
And then we had the added benefit of
David Stern banned it in the NBA.
So we immediately combined
what became a good ad,
said, banned in the NBA, and
every kid in the world wanted that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it hasn't been straight uphill.
We had a one year where our
sales actually went down.
But overall, we got together
with really good advertising,
which reflected his personality,
which was strong.
And it's been an unbelievable
success that when he quit playing,
sales of Jordan brand
product were $750 million.
And this last fiscal year, they topped
$3 billion long after he quit playing.
So I said to many people imagine how much
we would sell if he never played [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> We can only dream.
>> Phil, it's Nike's 55th
anniversary next week, I believe.
>> Yeah.
>> The company's at record revenue levels,
and just last year Nike
was voted alongside
Apple as the favorite brand of millenials.
And I think there's a few of us
in here who might attest to that.
How does a brand stay so relevant to so
many people for so long?
>> Well, it's hard work, but
you have to work at it all the time.
But I think our thing obviously
it starts with the product,
the product is by far our most
important marketing tool.
And so we're constantly
working to improve product.
And so
the kind of the recent up turn is because
we've had a really good product pipeline.
Probably, the React running shoe
is the number one on the list,
but there have been a lot of others and
so that's been really important.
And then good advertising
is critical to it.
The Wieden+Kennedy experience has been,
is in many
ways as dramatic as Nike's, and it's
really been kind of along side each other.
When I first met Dan Wieden, I walked
into the door of his quote office.
He had three people besides himself
sitting around the card table.
And he said welcome to Wieden+Kennedy and
I said, Dan,
just I want you to know just one thing,
I hate advertising.
And he looked at me and said,
well this will be interesting.
And it has been.
But it is interesting that obviously
if I had said that to Procter & Gamble,
they'd take your $25
advertising budget and
go on out the door But
they were a small advertising firm, and
he grew to understand that what I didn't
mean was that I hated advertising,
what I meant was that I hate traditional
advertising and he found ways to find out
who Nike is, or who Michael Jordan was and
project that to the consumer.
And not only did Nike succeed,
Kennedy now has offices all over
the world, over 1,000 employees.
It has Coca Cola as a client,
it has Honda as a client,
it has a lot of the world's
most famous brands as clients.
They've been an enormous success, and to
this day they work really hard at trying
to find out who it is and who the athlete
is and how to how to project them.
I know we had Boris Becker,
the great tennis players, and
we're trying to get him as an endorsement.
And Dan Widen, was making the pitch and
he says, we will find out who you are and
project that to the world.
And Boris says, how in the world can you
know who I am, when I don't know who I am?
[LAUGH] And just says,
well, we'll find out.
Well, we didn't make the sale,
we didn't sell them, but
that is one of the things I've done.
So the advertising and the product are two
of the really important things, and
then keeping the product fresh and
keeping advertising fresh.
And it's an ongoing challenge and
we don't always hit it.
A couple years ago we took
a little dip and it's a very,
very competitive business and every six
months there's kind of a new life and
everybody has to be aware of that.
>> Phil this is a school and
a speaker series dedicated to leadership.
So we want to make sure
we touch on that topic.
Something the MBA I class is challenged
with each year is why would someone
follow you?
I think, there can be a stereotype
of what a CEO should be.
Sometimes, we think of them as
a natural extrovert around the valley,
sometimes they can be
hero-like characters.
You described yourself as shy,
introverted,
someone who identifies
with the born loser.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's why [CROSSTALK]
>> But how have those traits helped you as
you built Nike?
>> Well, I think, I mean obviously
introverted people have tendency to listen
which I think good leaders do.
But when I was in school that, they talked
about two different types of leadership.
They talked about autocratic
leadership and democratic leadership.
And it was only 15 years after
World War II and they had
two of the great autocratic leaders ever,
Douglas MacArthur and George Patton.
And they at the time were looked
on as being very successful.
That then you have a democratic
style leadership which is,
the other thing is getting people
involved and talking to people.
So I think it's probably
almost impossible for
an introvert to be an autocratic leader.
But an introvert can be a democratic
leader and as the idea of democratic
leadership progressed, they started to
use the term collaborative leadership,
which is really, in my view, the ultimate
only kind of leadership to this day.
That in this day and age,
the autocratic leader doesn't work.
It can work for temporarily but
it won't work long run.
And I hope that the people in this
auditorium today don't get the idea
that hero leadership
means being autocratic.
I mean, obviously, I think Steve Jobs is
looked at as really kind of in this area,
the whole world really as being one of
the great leaders, which I believe he was.
But I do believe at the end of his career,
he was beginning to modify his natural
autocratic style which if you will, got
him fired as first tour around Apple and
as he got it to go through Apple a second
time, there was a change in Steve Jobs.
And you notice that from the commencement
speech he gave to Stanford University and
he hired Tim Cook and he had a lot
of give and take with Tim Cook.
And Tim Cook who I know quite well is
a very much collaborative leader, and
I believe a great collaborative leader.
So I think that it's just don't
equate hero leadership with
autocratic leadership.
The only task style of leadership
that will work in this day and
age is collaborative leadership.
>> Okay, Phil, another thing they
know about this group is that we're
a pretty touchy-feely bunch these days.
Of course, in your book you describe
business as war without bullets.
>> Yeah.
>> So, as you look back on those early
days in Nike dealing with those crises,
were soft skills tools an entrepreneur
like you could really afford back then?.
>> What type of skills
are you talking about?
>> The softer skills,
the touchy-feely skills.
>> I think yeah, I mean,
yeah, I think that.
If you read the book Shoe Dog,
obviously, I don't come across as
a touchy-feely type, and
neither were any of those top five.
But there's lots of different
ways of communicating.
And one of the things I don't like
about the politically correct movement
is that to me, politically correct
has been founded by people that
couldn't communicate, and they don't want
you to communicate very well either.
Because communication is really,
is a kind of an individual thing.
Everybody's a little bit different.
It's like people have
different fingerprints,
they have different personalities,
they have different emotions.
And I think the leader's job
is to know who his team is and
there is different ways to
communicate with that team.
We weren't touchy-feely in the sense that
we are always patting each other back and
say how we feel.
But you could say, how are you
doing today, you son of a bitch and
mean the same thing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so there's just
different ways to do that.
>> I think we need to bring that into
the chatter on campus these days.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now, Phil, we also study a lot here,
how leaders act in times of crisis, and
Nike and yourself have dealt with several.
Today the Nike brand is stronger than
ever but of course in the late 90s,
Nike did for some time become synonymous
with sweat shops, and slave wages.
As you look back how do you
feel you handled that crisis,
what would you do differently,
and what are you most proud of?
>> Well, one of the things
that we didn't talk about in business
school when I was here was the media.
And so I think probably this group Is
probably much more aware of the media.
But it's always there, it's more
prevalent than it's ever been and
they're not always consumed by facts.
That and so
when the first charges came that
Nike runs sweatshops
that it's really a seductive
argument to say,
this person only makes $4 a day, and
Michael Jordan makes $30 million a year,
and Phil Knight's worth $2 million
dollars, and isn't this awful.
But our initial reaction was
that we don't run sweatshops.
And that you're wrong.
And I was the CEO at the time, and
that was my strategy, and it was awful.
It didn't work.
And so we kind of after about
a year of that it became clear.
And so we took another tack which says
yeah you can criticize who you want but
this is what we're going to be and this is
how were going to be a better company over
the next 10 years and we're going
to take these steps each year and
you come look at any of our factories
anywhere in the world that you want.
And we've kind of been on that path
ever since and that's basically working.
And I do think that
we have had lots of good comments that
don't get much publicity from the media.
And one of the good ones was a member of
the United Nations says Nike's the gold
standard for all apparel companies
in how they run their factories.
And it's a constant battle though,
because we're always kind of looking for
new factories or changing factories.
And most of our shoe factories and
our good apparel factories have been
with us for 20 or 25 years, but
economics change at different times so you
do change some of them on the periphery.
So it's a constant battle to live
up to the standards we have.
But we have a whole team at Nike
that does that all the time and
basically is talking to people on
the production line all the time.
And, I do think that our factories
are the best in the world right now for
conditions and it's a basic truth that
great shoes are made by great factories.
You don't want a bad factory making
the best shoes in the world.
>> Now Phil, something else we
hear a lot from the media but
also occasionally at
Stanford is to find and
follow your passion and
you are perhaps the example of someone who
built a business dedicated to something
they love, which is sports and athletes.
There's many of us in the room today
who I feel they are struggling
to maybe tie our true passions
to a viable business or career.
What would you say to people like us?
>> Well, I think, you know, that one
thing that is left out is that you've
got to have a niche,
you've got to have a reason to succeed.
My reason that was that, you know,
Japan could make shoes economically, and
but then the rest of it fit
right in home base for me.
So and I do think if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it has to be something that
you really love because there
will be a lot of dark days.
And as I say we never hesitated
in those dark days so
I was fortunate enough to find what I
thought was a niche to go with my passion,
and that's what you need to
bring those two things together.
But when you do, you're very,
very fortunate and take advantage of it.
>> All right, well, look, Phil,
this has been brilliant thus far.
I know Nike say there is no finish line.
We do need to finish in about 15 minutes.
Phil, this has been brilliant.
We're almost going to let you go,
not quite yet.
There's a little tradition we
like to do up here, on stage,
we call the lightning round.
So the idea is, I'm going to ask
you a set of either-or questions.
We want you to answer the one answer
that comes first in your mind, okay?
>> [LAUGH]
>> You didn't warn me about this.
>> You didn't tell me you were going to
mention me mom.
>> I might get back to her.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, look.
Because it's a new thing
we're going to start easy and
then we'll get harder, okay?
So Jordan or LeBron?
>> No.
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE]
>> It's like asking which of your kids do
you like better.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You can tell me backstage it's fine.
>> Rose Bowl or Super Bowl?
>> Rose Bowl.
>> 3:40 mile or two-hour marathon?
>> Two hour marathon.
>> Nice, suit or track suit?
>> Man, track suit.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just do it, or dream crazy?
>> Just do it.
>> Hawaii or Palm Springs?
>> Hawaii.
>> Beatles or Rolling Stones?
>> Beatles.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was easy.
>> Breaking Bad or The Sopranos?
>> Ooh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Probably Sopranos but that's tough.
[LAUGH]
>> We were told it was tough for you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Adidas or barefoot?
>> Barefoot.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, Phil Knight.
>> Thanks, it was fun.
[MUSIC]